play stay safe she was 12 years old when
Sony Music signed her Alex Bruce has
been described as the future of Filipino
hip-hop
now 16 she's released 10 tracks the
teenager from Batangas south of Manila
says she got her musicality from her
parents her dad was in a band but her
influences range from Old School all the
way to K-pop
trap is like the new school type of
hip-hop the beats are very simply I used
to like trap a lot I still do like trap
a lot but I like to mix it with like the
fusion of old school hip-hop
unlike many of the Trap beats with
lyrics that revolve around sex drugs and
violence Alex says hers reflect her
Youth and aspiration for more Filipino
women to break out into the local
hip-hop scene when you ask like somebody
anybody like what do you think about
Raph what do you think about hip-hop
what comes to their mind is always like
sex money drugs you know and I'm here to
like prove them wrong to change the
mindset of people
the Philippines was the first country in
Asia to embrace hip-hop the local scene
is still heavily influenced by American
rap music but some of the most famous
Filipino hip-hop artists have also used
their music to push for social change
easily one of the top Filipino hip-hop
artists of all time raps about the brain
drain crime poverty
and social inequality
and he actively campaigned in the
presidential election last year I can't
always play safe I don't need Bashers on
my timeline I don't need negative
comments about me but then I realized I
have to show my children
that if you believe in something
you have to stand for it it's outspoken
comments aren't unique to Filipino
hip-hop artists Thailand's rap against
dictatorship actively performed during
mass pro-democracy protests in 2020 two
of their members were charged with
sedition for that
South Korea's BTS arguably the biggest
boy band to have emerged from Asia have
appeared at the United Nations General
Assembly and received an invite to the
White House too the music will
categorized as K-pop very much as
elements of hip-hop proof of genres and
cultures merging and how hip-hop has
evolved to entertain the world
born below Al Jazeera Manila